you do a wicked Harrison Ford impression
will you do it for me nothing like that
he's always not gonna the half-smile can
you do Harrison Ford of course I can my
knees mark hamill nailed it I'm just
saying he set the bar really high
[Music]
gargling your saliva so good at it
because I was a I'm what about when
they're kind of under pressure you've
said before that actually being on a
Star Wars set looks comedic even though
it's a dramatic you know Star Wars is on
the surface it's an action family you
know adventure movie but in between
takes it's pure comedy I get way means
to say some of it you have to take a
step back and be like easy that's what
we do for a living every moment that
you're there it's something interesting
them just the whole sequence of running
around the Death Star was fun cuz you're
acting out all these scenarios that used
to play in your backyard so when you
read the script for this one were you
surprised yeah for sure yeah yeah I had
well I just had no idea how the job to
kind of take characters that were
established and still make them
three-dimensional in the midst of this
world that everyone's familiar with and
then at the same time push the
boundaries or do things that have never
been seen in their Star Wars movie
balancing all of that knowing that
people aren't gonna care about an
explosion or any ship or poorer or
whatever if there's not something human
about it I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
[Music]
you
[Music]